bonjour les proches de mail ir incombe
hervé n'ont pas vu ce sourire depuis
près de quatre mois
l'avis de la martiniquaise de 59 ans a
basculé le 21 octobre dernier date de
son incarcération en iran la chef
d'entreprise étaient arrivés la veille
dans le pays pour un voyage d'affaires
de trois jours depuis famille et amis
sont dans l'angoissé
madame ra s'est déplacé pour un week-end
d'aller voir sur place du minerai qui
était soi disant à négocier et elle
devait rentrer lundi à les partis le
samedi elle devait rentrer le lundi le
dimanche matin d'après les dires il
semblerait qu'elle ait été convoqué pour
aller sur une île voir ce fameux minerai
depuis plus de nouvelles
après une semaine de silence radio une
autre à me contacter le ministère des
affaires étrangères et l'ambassade de
france en iran
c'est là qu'elle apprend l'arrestation
de nesle hier incombe et revel la femme
d'affaires est accusé d'achats illégale
d'or
joint par téléphone le quai d'orsay ne
souhaite pas s'exprimer sur la sphère le
ministère précise qu'une protection
consulaire a été mise en place ainsi que
des visites en prison
mais pour ses proches le temps est
compté il lance un appel à la solidarité
neely a des problèmes de santé il vous
faut réagir
la justice iranienne réclame pour sa
caution libérateur à la somme de 4
milliards de rials correspondant
approximativement à 40000 euros
une cagnotte a été mise en place sur les
six points comme afin de réunir cette
somme qui sera versée au trésor public
et transmis à l'ambassade de france en
iran les amis de nelly incomber revel
redoute un coup monté
devant le silence des autorités
françaises difficile d'en savoir plus
l'avenir de la chef d'entreprise
martiniquaise reste incertain